Welcome to Carl T. Wedane Elementary. We
are the proud home of Wedane Wildcats.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. I love it. I love
it.
[applause]
So, I do just want to start off by
saying it it means a lot just to see
everyone turn out to come out for our
meetings and just being part of the
conversation. Uh, and also want a big a
heartfelt thank you to the Mr.
Superintendent Matias and his team just
kind of making sure they create a space
for us to kind of voice have a a space
for us to voice how we feel and what
we're thinking and how we can navigate
this together. So much graciasto
ISD. So turn it over.
>> Good evening everyone. Thank you so much
for joining us. My name is Ally
Gillarduchcci. I'm the senior executive
director of communications and community
engagement. Um before we get started in
the content, we just want to talk about
what you can expect today. Um so we just
did our welcome. We are going to briefly
go over some meeting norms and just the
purpose of the meeting. Um then we are
going to introduce our panel, the folks
that we have here that can help respond
to questions. Um then we will provide
you with an overview of what are what
are the proposals that the proposed
changes that are currently in the draft
plan so that we all are on the same page
about what's currently being proposed.
Um and then we want to and that's so
that we can hear from y'all understand
what's working, what your concerns are.
Um and that's so that we could
potentially inform any potential changes
to the draft. Um then we y'all submitted
questions via the comment card. Thank
you so much to everyone who submitted
those questions. You have QR codes on
your table. Um that card is actually
open until tonight. So if you think of
anything after this meeting you want to
submit, get it in today. Um but we
pulled questions from there and we're
going to answer some of those questions
that came up frequently in your
comments. And then the last 45 minutes
or so is going to be just Q&A and time
for us to hear any questions we maybe
haven't answered from the comment cards.
And then we'll just talk about next
steps. Um, so I just want to briefly go
over meeting norms. Um, we're here
because we want to build the future
together. We want to acknowledge the
challenges that, um, our district is
currently facing while focusing on ideas
and solutions that will make our
district stronger, more equitable, and
sustainable for years to come. Um, we
want to honor time. So, when we do get
to the Q&A, we're going to ask that
people attempt to limit your comments to
about a minute just because we have a
lot of folks here and we want to make
sure there's space for everyone. Um, we
want to honor the process. So that means
following along with the agenda. Um,
staying on course. Um, honoring intent
and impact. So, we know that we may
disagree on things, but I think that we
can all hopefully agree that one thing
that we all have in common is our goal
to have strong, equitable schools to
serve our students. Um, we want to honor
space and voice. And what we mean by
that is if you do get called on to
speak, um we're going to make sure that
before we get to you a second time that
everyone else who hasn't spoken has an
opportunity. Um we want to stay
solutionoriented as much as possible. So
focusing on ideas, solutions, and
understanding. Um and then we're here to
embrace transparency and empathy. You
have our commitment that we're going to
tell you what we know, what we believe
is possible, what we what constraints we
might be facing. Um, and we want to just
we recognize these are really hard
conversations and that we are asking
families to experience a fair amount of
change and we understand that and we're
here to understand how we can move
forward and make that an easier
transition if that is what we end up um
pursuing.
Um, the norms are here in Spanish for
y'all.
Um, and then just to reiterate the
meeting purpose. Um, so like we said, we
want to make sure we respond. We know
that we got some questions that came up
over and over again in the comment
cards. So, we're going to go ahead and
come out and answer those right away for
y'all. Um, then we also, like I said,
want to gain a shared understanding of
what the proposed changes are and some
of the rationale or the why. Why, you
know, we saw a lot of questions. Well,
why this instead of that, right? And so,
we're going to explain our thought
process um behind all of those
proposals. Um, but what we really want
to know is, um, we want to gain insights
from you that are going to help us
inform potential changes to the draft
plan because we released a draft and
this Friday, we are going to be
releasing a revised version of that
draft and it through conversations that
we've had with communities through the
comment cards. We have read every single
one of those, every single idea. If we
hadn't already explored it, we made sure
that we looked and explored it. And you
will see this Friday that many
adjustments will be made from that
initial plan. Um it may not be every
adjustment you were hoping for, but we
are making adjustments and it is
directly based on the feedback we hear
from y'all. So um that's a big part of
why we're here today. Um because
ultimately we want to get a final draft
presented to our board on November 20th
and we want to make sure it it captures
the feedback that you have shared with
us. Um, so with that, I'm going to go
ahead and pass it to our superintendent
to talk a little bit about the vision
for this process and then we'll dive
into kind of what's proposed in the
questions.
>> Sorry.
>> Thank you, Ally. Um, so first off, I
just want to say thank you uh to all of
our families and staff uh for being here
this afternoon. Uh, it's not lost on me.
This is a commitment of time. Uh, we
very much appreciate you engaging. Uh,
as Ally said, this is a draft plan. your
feedback uh what you share with us will
help us move forward. Uh and so I just
wanted to say thank you. Thank you. Um I
also want to acknowledge that this is a
very disruptive,
painful process. Um and I want you all
to know that I just apologize that we're
having to go through this. Uh it's never
something I thought I would have to be a
part of. Um, but given where we are as a
school district, we have to do
something. Uh, the way that we have been
operating, the way that we have been
supporting our students cannot continue
on if we're going to evolve as a school
district.
Our goal as a school district is to
ensure that every student
gets what they need to be successful.
Period.
Right. And what we know is that in
Austin ISD for decades,
black and brown students, students who
have been historically underserved have
not gotten what they need to be
successful. And we know that. Look at
where our schools are. Look at how the
resources have been deployed for
decades. And I would argue that if we
keep doing those things, our students
who look like me, who look like many of
you in this room, are not going to get
what they need from us.
Austin ISD, the organization that I
lead, has to change.
So we talk about what that change looks
like. We talk about having strong
neighborhood schools.
A neighborhood,
right? We want our families not to feel
like they have to go across town to get
to a strong neighborhood school, but
some families feel as though they need
to do that.
We want students that not only do well
on a test, but love learning, love
reading. Like, that's what we want.
And the reality of it all is that we do
have strong schools and we do have
strong neighborhood schools, but they're
not everywhere.
And so we as a school district have to
do something to evolve. And we have to
do it at a time when there is immense
pressure everywhere
from the state
and not fully funding public education
from the federal government and the
challenges that it's pushed and placed
on our immigrant families
right to the everchanging accountability
system
that's changed multiple times in the
last three
like what we do moving forward has to be
mindful of all of this. And so this
plan,
there's a lot in it and it covers the
entire district, but there are several
things in it that we hope to accomplish.
One,
we wanted to make sure that every
student in Austin ISD was in an aligned
feeder pattern. Well, what does that
mean? It means if you're in an
elementary school, you go to no more
than one or two middle schools. And if
you're in a middle school, you go to no
more than one or two high schools.
You keep community together. Programming
alignment improves.
We have schools that have feeder
patterns like that.
They're not in East Austin.
In East Austin, we have schools that
have four and five high schools that
they go to. You cannot keep community
together if you continue to have those
splits. This plan aims to clean up and
align those feeder patterns. Two,
we have budget challenges, y'all. We
just do. We invest in our educators. We
put money where our teachers are and in
our classrooms, but the cost of
education is rising every single year.
and no one's helping us out. We've
gotten some funding from the state, but
it didn't really move the needle. So, we
have to figure out how do we find
resources and how we distribute them to
ensure that they're going to our
students who need them the most. So, we
got to become more efficient. Three,
we have to address these transfer
policies that have been in place for
decades.
They're moving students all throughout
Austin and are giving families the
ability to navigate different ways and
moving students from their communities
to other parts of Austin. Now, there's
reasons why they occurred in the past,
but we really have to look at them as we
move forward. So, that's part of this
plan as well. Four,
certain programs have evolved over the
last many years. In Austin ISD, we
believe in dual language.
There are school districts all across
central Texas that are moving away from
dual language. Not us. We're leaning
into it.
But there are some programs who just
because of how the city has grown
the student population in the walls of
that school of those schools that it was
originally intended for. So our emerging
bilingual students.
So, if we're going to support these
programs, we have to create access and
move those programs to where our
students live. That's part of the plan.
And then lastly,
this plan has to be responsive to the
accountability pressures in the state of
Texas that we are facing. It's not lost
on me that in Wedane in 2022
had an accountability rating that was
academically successful. Y'all know that
the same kids, the same teachers the
following year had an unacceptable
rating. That just shows you how much
that test changed in one year.
So, we have to adjust ourselves because
the state's not changing.
So, this plan has to be responsive to
it. And if we are not responsive to it,
then the state will take everinccreasing
interventions
and introduce risks that could at some
point take away local control. It's
happening right now in the state of
Texas in the last week with a school
district that looks very similar to
Austin ISD.
So, we have to do all of this together.
This plan is a draft plan. We're
refining it. We're improving it. But I
want you to know that each of these
things is woven in together and every
time you make a change in one school or
one program, it impacts another. And so
we'll go through the impacts for Wedane.
We're really um hopeful that you have an
share with us y'all's concerns,
thoughts, ways that we can improve. It's
not a perfect plan. No plan is given how
complex that it is. Uh but I wanted to
share with you kind of why this plan
looks the way that it does. Go to the
next slide. So the plan So in this plan
for Woodane Elementary School
acknowledging a couple things. The first
is that we have lots of seats in this
area um empty seats and there's over
20,000 in Austin ISD.
And so this plan attempts to remove some
of them by going through boundary
changes and consolidations.
And so Wedane also acknowledging that we
have to respond to a turnaround plan
arrives at this draft scenario. Wedane
Elementary School will move into
Rodriguez Elementary School and into
Houston Elementary School. The percent
of students will be about 70% to
Rodriguez, 30% to Houston. This is based
on geography and kind of where our
students live and where our students
live in proximity to those schools.
So, the plan, and you see the the little
kind of the size how it's a little bit
bigger.
Um, Rodriguez Elementary School would be
the school that receives the turnaround
plan that's required by the state of
Texas for Wedane. And so as we work with
that campus, if this plan moves forward,
then Rodriguez would be um the school
that is responsible for breaking that
turnaround plan. And we I mean the
turnaround um breaking the um the
accountability chain and that would be
the obligation between the entire
community. And then Houston Elementary
School is going through a modernization.
I certainly want to acknowledge that
this they don't have the same historical
uh ratings. Uh there's fluctuation. We
know they're they're a D prior to that
there but they're not um a three
unacceptable rating. They're a two. And
based on what we're seeing there with
the investments, we do believe that
they're moving in the right direction
and they'll be able to break their
accountability chain as well. So you can
see uh this is being thought kind of
responsive to the number of seats we
have in the area as well as addressing
the um turnaround plan required by the
state of Texas.
Um so I'll go ahead and cover this. So
what does this mean for your student
next year? Well, if you live in the
current uh elementary school boundary,
you would attend either Rodriguez or
Houston. Uh we have um a tool on our
website where you can go and add your
address and it'll tell you precisely
which school you will go to. If you are
a transfer student into uh Wedane, we
are going to be sharing with our board
and with our community that you will be
able to move uh with your cohort as you
choose. Meaning that if you transfer in
and you know your community is going to
Rodriguez, then we would approve that
transfer. If you prefer to choose uh
Houston, then we would approve that as
well. That is a superintendent level
decision. I want to make sure that our
community stays together as best we can
and that's way we can that's one way
that we can help do that. You want to
speak to this Christine?
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you everyone. My name is Christine
Steampport. I'm the operations officer
for Austin ISD. So I just kind of want
to walk through the boundary maps um and
talk a little bit about that. So this
boundary map is the existing Wedane
boundary. So this boundary is the
existing Wedane boundary. So if you live
in here, you would you're assigned to
Wedane. And so since this school is
proposed for a closure, this is what you
see as the boundary. And so this little
piece, so what this is called is called
a little bit of feathering. You may or
may not have heard that term. when we
redraw boundaries to imbalance our
enrollment through all of our schools
and make sure that we're at a healthy
range of utilization for how big that
school is versus how many kids live in
that area. Um, I'll kind of walk you
through why some of these little squares
are a little bit different. So, this is
why I know Superintendent Sigura kind of
walked us through how most of the
students will go to Wedane based off
where they live, excuse me, Rodriguez,
based off where they live and where that
boundary is redrawn. So if this boundary
is no more, this um part would go to
Rodriguez and then this part would be
reszoned to Houston. So if you want to
go through the other maps and this just
kind of shows Houston's boundary and the
changes there for Perez. So that bit of
that feathering, that domino effect of
shifting and moving. And then uh this is
that piece that you saw on the previous
map. So just wanted to point that out.
And then this is Rodriguez's as well. So
this piece here would go to Rodriguez.
And so that just kind of showcases that.
So I just wanted to walk through kind of
those three boundary changes and the
shifts. And if there's any questions,
happy to walk through it anymore.
And just the last piece that we wanted
to talk about. Do you want me to talk
about the turnaround plan? Sure. So we
just want to make sure that everyone's
clear on the turnaround plan. So as you
know, Wedane requires a turnaround plan.
Um, TEA wants to see to the best ability
possible if we have to reassign students
that we do what we can to get the
majority of students into a school that
is higher rated. So, Rodriguez is one of
those schools that is higher rated,
which is why we have assigned the
majority of students to that school. Um,
as Superintendent Sigura said, when
there is a turnaround plan, um, that
plan and a school closes, that plan
follows the students. So Rodriguez would
inherit the Wedane turnaround plan and
that would become that combined schools
turnaround plan. So we're drafting those
plans now. If they are approved that and
that work would start together for the
two school communities to work together
to refine that plan because they're
there that joined school community will
have to adopt and implement that plan.
um the principal for the schools when
we're consolidating schools. Those are
going to be decisions that are made um
administratively by our superintendent.
Um and we recognize that there's a lot
of uncertainty in this process. So, one
of the things that we're going to try to
to provide some certainty on is once we
have a vote in November and we know what
changes have been approved, um we will
be appointing principles for any of
these consolidated schools in December.
And that allows that principal then to
begin to start figuring out what the
staffing will be. So we know we get a
lot of questions for example about maybe
you have certain services your child
receives and you want to know are they
going to have the same teacher or are
they going to receive those services? Um
we want to get that principal um in
place and figured out so that they can
start figuring out which staff. And one
thing that we um haven't talked about
yet but is we have a staffing guideline
u guide book that we've created. It's
also on our consolidation page in the
resources and it outlines when we have
school communities coming together, we
want to make sure that wherever our kids
end up that they have familiar faces.
So, we want to make sure that students
at Rodriguez still have teachers and um
staff that they recognize, but we also
want to make sure that Wedane students
that would be going to Rodriguez would
also have faces that they would
recognize. So our goal is going to be to
look at what percent of the students at
this combined school come from Woodane,
what percent are at Rodriguez or
Houston, and then trying to make the
staffing um more or less meet that. So
if you have if it's say it's 50/50, then
about half the staff we would want to
try to be at one school and about half
the staff would be from the other so
that everyone has those familiar faces.
Um it won't be perfect of course, but
that's going to be our goal. Um and then
if there are any current staff that
don't find themselves landing either in
in um Rodriguez or Houston, at that
point we are going to hold um career
fairs and placement um events so that we
can identify other places in Austin ISD
where they can continue to serve because
our goal is to find a home for everyone
that we can um rather than trying in a
typical year we would be trying to hire
staff starting in early spring to staff
for the next school year. This year, we
don't need to look outside our district,
right? Because we're going to have staff
that's freed up and we want to make sure
we find homes for them. Um, and then the
last piece is any school that has a
turnaround plan. So, y your school would
be one, whether it's both at the one
that goes over with students to
Rodriguez or the one at Houston, those
campuses are going to receive a
significant investment of extra
resources to support that turnaround
plan. Um, so this pro whole process does
free the whole point of us doing this
process, one of the big goals is to free
up dollars to put them where they're
needed most, right? And so we know our
schools that have those turnaround plans
need those extra resources so they can
then hire positions like extra
counselors to support the transition.
Um, extra content interventionists who
can support students who maybe need a
little extra curriculum help um or
instructional coaches to support our
teachers. So those schools will get
extra resources and they can kind of
decide how they need to spend those
resources based on the goals they set in
their turnaround plan. Um and so with
that, we are going to go ahead and start
with the presubmitted questions that we
had in the comment cards. Um and if you
have any follow-up questions while we're
going through it, we're happy to um also
address those. So I'm going to start
with the first one, and this one came
from multiple commenters. Um could you
explain the turnaround plan requirements
from the Texas Education Agency? Why are
students from Wedane being reassigned to
another school that requires a
turnaround plan? So, we've kind of
touched on that.
>> Yeah. So, um the state of Texas requires
turnaround plans whenever you have two
unacceptable ratings or they call them
unacceptable uh counts. And what made
this last uh year very challenging is
that we had 2023 accountability, 2024
accountability, and 2025 accountability
all come out within five months. Do you
remember? Because there were lawsuits
that took place. And so what the agency
says is if you are drafting an
accountability plan, a turnaround plan,
you have six strategies that you can
use. And typically you're drafting those
on your second UA or unacceptable
accountability rating count. Uh and so
what happened is you have six that you
can evaluate. Now if you grab if you get
your third unacceptable
uh count which we have here at Wedane,
there are certain ones that are
available but you know won't be
accepted. An example of this would be um
like a restart or a new school. If
you're in a year two, you could restart,
have a new school, but the second year
would give you one whole year to plan.
And then year three, you would implement
that plan. In year four, you would break
the chain, and in year five, you would
get out. because all of it came together
in a relatively short period of time. Uh
we had to draft and build turnaround
plans that we knew would be accepted and
ones that we felt um met the time that
we have to address the rating. So once
we get we're in year three, right? So
we're starting year we have to get
through year three and year four. If you
get into year five, if you start the
fifth year and the students take the
STAR exam and do not break the
accountability chain, the state of Texas
can intervene and install a board of
managers, which is replacing the board
and the superintendent. And then so for
us there are um different uh available
options but I will tell you that when
you work with the agency they will tell
you
you have six but you really should only
be looking at three. And so when we have
these conversations we're always testing
you know what would this look like or
how could this possibly work in Austin
ISD. We get that feedback and then we
take the next step in producing these
plans. Um, and so whenever it comes to
reassignment, because I would one of the
approved strategies to reassign the
students to a school that's academically
acceptable.
So in its simplest form, if there was a
school that historically had been not
met accountability and there was an
A-rated school, the state's perspective
would say just move all the kids to the
A-rated school. Break the accountability
chain. That's what they would say is the
best option.
in cases where you have lots of schools
that all have different uh kind of um
programs and different um kind of
different challenges. We can't always
it's not that simple. So for us, we had
to really think about where did we have
a school that would meet the criteria of
being academically acceptable so they
could carry the the turnaround plan. And
what the state says is the majority of
the students have to go to that school.
We could not do it the other way. If the
majority of the students went to
Houston, that would not be accepted. Uh
and so there are other options. You can
do a restart where this uh AISD restarts
the entire school. Uh we did that
recently at Dolby, Bernett, and Web. Uh
there are restarts with an 1882 partner,
right? That's what Mendes looks like.
And we know as a school district that,
you know, we would prefer, strongly
prefer to have our students be educated
by our staff, our way you with our
values. We also have um other options
including um kind of resource schools,
but those are typically for two-year um
turnaround um plan options. So, there's
different options. There's six in total,
but ultimately when you have three UAS
as we have here at Wedane, you have
fewer options. Go ahead. Question.
>> You have a microphone?
>> Can you come?
>> Or I can maybe restate your question if
I can. We're recording so it would
really help if you could speak in the
mic so that it is caught on the
>> video. Sorry about that.
>> I think this might be as far as we go.
>> So my question is more about the
unacceptable ratings. Um you mentioned
that we had three unacceptable ratings
that all came out at one time. Now, in a
previous meeting with Miss Pace, she did
say AISD was aware that some schools had
three unacceptable waitings, but y'all
sat back and I think the word was that
you hoped that the one that was tied up
in litigation would not be released. And
so my question is, why was AISD not
proactive? Why were they not here and
say, "Hey, regardless of what happens
with TEA, regardless if this 2023
accountability rating comes out, your
obligation is to our students." And so
if it comes out or not, if the
litigation comes out or not, you all
knew that our school had 3F. So where
was the proactive Yeah.
>> staff? Where was extra staff? Where was
extra tutors? Any of that? That that's
what I would like to know.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
[applause]
So,
first off, we we never hoped um we were
not in the lawsuit. Uh you know, we uh
felt strongly that if we were going to
uh improve academics and improve
outcomes in Austin ISD, we were going to
do it our way. So, what does our way
look like? Well, it means that in 2022,
2023, you had massive vacancies all
throughout Austin ISD. Think about that
time. We're two years removed from the
pandemic. You know, our fill rate, our
staffing rate was in the low 80s. Now,
we're at 97%. So, we said we need
educators in the classroom, right? First
and foremost, we need to build systems.
We need to align our curriculum. We need
to invest in instructional coaches,
which we did. We need to invest in
content interventions which we have. We
need to go and pass a tax rate election
to get uh compensation increase for our
teachers. Like all these things we were
doing and have been doing. So I don't
want anybody in this room or outside
this room to think that for the last two
and a half years we were not moving the
system. Now could you go quicker? You
could, but you're probably going to
adopt behaviors and strategies that do
not align for who we are. So what we
said is let's build out thoughtful
response and um initiatives. Let's align
with the scorecard that the board
approved in the uh summer of 2024 and
that was our strategy. Now we 23 24 25
we knew that the schools had been making
progress. many of our schools have um
honestly when the a when the uh
accountability came out it did put
pressure on our system but we don't want
to do is to lean into something that we
don't believe in. Uh but I don't want
anybody to believe that urgency wasn't
there or that we weren't deploying
resources where we could. We were coming
out of a period of disruption and trying
to improve the entire system. That is so
that's that was what we were doing and
that's how we tackled it. So we never
hoped. I mean
>> that's not true. No.
Yeah. So, what I would say is um that's
not we weren't doing it everywhere.
That's that's I want to be really clear.
What we did um in 23 24 is we created a
source u a resource index so that we and
we organized all of our schools and we
looked at student demographics and we
said if you are in this band then we are
going to ensure that from a staffing
perspective a resource perspective you
are supported in a different way and our
principles understood that our system
understood that and that is how we
responded so no we did not apply the
same thing to every school. We're very
intentional. In fact, in many cases, we
actually held minimums where he would
have otherwise made more aggressive
decisions and we said, "No, we're not
going to do that." And there are lots of
examples of that. Um, but I don't want
anybody to think that what we that we
were homogeneous in our approach to how
we supported our students. That was not
the case. In fact, we went out of our
way to produce a index that allowed our
operations folks, our finance folks, our
talent strategy folks to make decisions
based on need. and that's how we've been
operating ever since.
>> Um, I think we have a follow-up question
here, Matias.
>> So, I've been on this campus for 10
years, and I'm sorry, sir, with all due
respect, you really didn't answer the
question because I have been here from
the very beginning. I was I've been here
since before Miss Pace was the principal
here. And I, me working here, being with
the kids, being in it every day, did not
feel the difference in the past three
years. We had we have had three
different executive directors in the
past three years and before
>> Mr. Medina
I saw me saw them maybe two three times
on the campus. Now whether they met with
Mr. F or they met with Miss Chilton at
the time or whoever that was unbeknownst
to us and whatever strategies that were
put in place
I mean we we have made progress. I we
are looking for an actual factual
answer, not just the political answer.
What was done here?
>> You want to speak to that? [applause]
>> Here at Wedane Elementary School, not in
the area, not for Rodriguez, not for for
whatever, not us numbers on a on a piece
of paper on a spreadsheet here at
Wedane. What was done here when our
intervention is
>> Okay.
Thank you, Miss Fawn. Uh so as
superintendent Siguro was saying some of
the things that have been done
specifically for Wedane um as well as
some other campuses that have been
struggling is providing an instructional
coach providing a content
interventionist
providing
in addition to that when we level
because classes are underenrolled
these campuses are protected from losing
teachers. Even if the classes are not
quite full enough um to maintain, we're
leveling
smaller class sizes impact learning. And
let me just say this you guys. I just
want to say this. Part of the reason for
the consolidation plan is not just
accountability, but when we are under
budget, when we have a budget deficit
and we cannot provide the supports that
campuses need and there's campuses that
are similar to Wedane that have three
unacceptable ratings that we don't have
the funds to because you may not need
just one instructional coach or just one
content interventionist. You may need
multiple. You may need to have quite a
few classrooms that are under 18. We
cannot do that when we are operating 116
campuses and many of them have needs.
And so that is part of the plan for
consolidation is because we know you
need more and we want to be able to give
that.
>> Um we have another question. Does is it
related to this or something a different
topic? Okay, go right ahead.
Okay. I'm a parent volunteer. I'm here
pretty much every day helping out the
school. Uh my daughter goes to this
school. I understand the need for
consolidation and the need to meet
budgets and everything that your your
proposal is attempting to to achieve. Um
I disagree with a lot of the solutions
that you've chosen. Um, a lot of the
solutions in the proposal indicate one
reason, but they appear to be due to
accountability, but they say it's
something else.
My point on the turnaround that uh that
we're discussing here is that Austin I
should ISD and none of the other schools
in Texas should be going through
turnarounds right at the moment because
those scores were not provided per Texas
law. Um, Texas Educational Code 39.05.
054 A3 requires that those scores be
provided by August 15th of each year.
Okay. Since those scores weren't
provided, this the commissioner should
have provided a not rated score to all
the schools so that anybody that's in
the condition that we are where we're
trying to improve our school and get
back into accountability has additional
time to do that and the scores weren't
available to react upon. Um and so I
think that if we could present that the
commissioner should have provided us
with not rated on those scores, we can
actually adjust the um consolidation
that we need to in a more effective way
that a closes schools that should be
closed. Um, for example, like Becker is
the um current dual language school in
the south and I can understand wanting
to close that school because they're 29%
emergent dual language there and we want
to move it to a higher population dual
emergent dual language school. Well,
Rodriguez is a perfect example of a
school that would be available for
emergent language dual language or
emergent uh dual language school. um and
then split the difference between
Houston and Wedane again as if the
turnaround was not an odd on the table.
That would put both schools in a better
geographic position for all the students
that are in this area so that they have
a shorter commute to school.
Rodriguez would be a better commute for
anybody in the south for getting to the
wall-to-wall dual language school
compared to Sanchez, which would
increase it would basically shut off the
dual language capability to anybody in
the south because it's north side of the
river. And so there's just some
solutions that and and that's just in
the south end. I I see sections in other
parts and I'm writing a counter proposal
that I hope to have to you guys this
week um so that you can review what
other options would be available if the
turnaround thing were taken off the
table. Yeah.
>> So, um thank you.
>> I want to be honest with y'all. You have
to
the turnaround plans. The commissioner,
the Texas education agency
has already proven and demonstrated to
other school districts
that the environment we're in is not
going away.
They upheld the lawsuits, districts
lost. That's the honest truth. They have
immense power. They have the authority
to do everything I said. There is
nothing that we can do that's going to
keep us from having to submit these
plans. And if we do not submit them, I
promise you the response will be
aggressive and it will take more control
and hurt our students and create more
harm than we can probably even like
comprehend. Like that that I I
appreciate that because that's what
school districts fought for, right? in
2023. That's precisely what the lawsuit
was about is that school districts were
not given enough time to actually adjust
to the new STAR test. It had what
hundreds of school districts sue in the
courts and the commissioner won.
Period.
So, I I don't want I I I don't want our
community to to spend energy on
something that is not on the table
because it's not. I just I know that our
commissioner and our agency is not going
to allow us to not submit these
turnaround plans and I as the leader of
this organization have to submit them. I
have to because if I don't then what
happens if you do not submit a plan and
it's not accepted you have 45 days to
submit a new plan. If that plan is not
accepted you have 15 days. If that
plan's not accepted, the state can move
forward and install a board of managers,
which is replace all of your trustees.
You lose local control. It's what
happening in Fort Worth right now. And
then replace the superintendent and you
can and then you're back into that
period of disruption. So, I appre I want
to see your proposal. I I very much exp
want to explore different ideas and
solutions, but I don't want to have you
all leave here thinking that's a viable
option because it's just not from my
perspective. And I know there are many
of the school districts that have
already fought that and have lost.
>> And Matias, I just want to add something
because I want to make sure everyone
followed when we talked about the
options that are available because we've
had conversations at Wedane, right? Um,
basically we have been told by ETA that
the when you get to that three
unacceptable, you have to either restart
that your school or you have to close it
and combine them with a higher
performing school, the majority of
students, right? Those are the only two
options that TEA is going to accept. And
so when we had um what's that?
>> Or partner with a with a charter to do
either of those things, right? Um and so
we had 13 schools that had that three
unacceptable and those were the choices,
right? We cannot restart every single
school, right? There wouldn't be enough
staff to meet the requirements to do
that. In some instances, we had to
reassign students to a school that is
already meeting that accountability that
TEA had. Otherwise, we would not be able
to recruit enough staff that met it just
to keep everyone.
>> So,
>> and we understand that and I think we
didn't do a great job of responding to
that piece. Um
>> the the fact is that Rodriguez does not
have quite enough room for all of fit,
right? But to tea, they want to see the
majority of students. If there are
follow-up questions, can I get folks to
come up because it's going to be hard to
hear folks and I'd like to try to have
one conversation at a time.
>> Okay.
>> I mean, I we're
>> Did you have some
>> Well, he has he asked a question about
Houston and being a 48 two years ago.
>> Yeah. So,
>> okay. Let's talk a little bit about
Houston and then we'll get to your
question. You're welcome to stay up
here, ma'am.
question.
>> So to the gentlemen, so there's a couple
things I want to acknowledge is that one
is we have so many schools that have
moved and are on the brink of getting a
D and pausing right there. There are
many there's nine schools that have 59s,
several that have 50A.
>> Houston is not one of them, but they're
also 2 UA. They're they have a they have
a a D in the middle that breaks up their
accountability chain and so they are one
year behind where Wedane is. That's the
honest truth. Now the other thing that I
would say is what I'm telling you is
feed based on feedback we have from the
agency whenever students are moved into
a new facility or whenever it's a
population that isn't the majority then
they do feel that is a viable option.
Now the alternative it would take all
students to Rodriguez right that's the
only other option and in that case could
it be done it would potentially create
an overenrollment issue at Rodriguez
which can lead to you know unsafe
conditions so that's really what we're
balancing I agree with you not every
plan is perfect
>> they don't know anyone
any
So, one of the things that we're going
to do, um,
>> folks, again, I'm going to ask that if
we want to ask questions, if we can get
to the mic, we're recording and it's not
going to pick up the voices that call.
>> Folks, can I have people, if you would
like to ask a question, please come.
Ma'am,
>> ma'am, could you ask your question up
here? We're happy to give you the mic if
folks want to get in line.
Yeah. I wanted to know what's going on
with the special education. My son have
autism with HD.
>> Yeah. So, uh, special education. So, our
students that receiving special
education services, uh, as I think this
most communities know, we have been
working very very hard over the last two
and a half years to improve our systems.
We under a TA read order of special
education, we place staff and resources
based on need. And so in this plan, the
way that it would work is based on where
your student is going to be located. We
would say, okay, what services are going
to be at either Rodriguez or Houston,
that is not a talent and strategy like
that's not um generally staffing. That
comes from our special education
department. And what they do is say okay
based on these students needs we are
going to place these staff here and if
that resource doesn't exist at that
school we will place them. That happens
all the time. So I will tell you
>> let me tell you something. Yeah
>> about the special education.
>> My son started a school when the co
start there supposedly he was going to
Houston. Houston I have a special
education but then I have a teacher at
that time. I come here and I find the
teacher NY and this is his house to my
son with eight years
he's working hard all the people here
the teachers
the principal know my son my son know
the school is just like a he can go here
because he know where is all the places
and you are thinking oh it's because the
school this is I understand
Houston.
I have a lot of comments from bullying
Rodriguez. They're complaints about
kids, their uh their suffering, uh their
accidents over there, bullying.
What can I expect with my son over
there?
And it's not only that.
It's hard when you have an asset with a
um a disability
when he come here.
The doctor told me he don't go have
empathy. It's going to be hard for him.
My son read I have empathy. He know that
how
>> no no that's not um
>> last
multiplication at five. He knows now I
fight because his teacher doing that job
because I have empathy for my son
because I take care of my son
because my son is someone here in the
school and you're saying oh this how
many years you was trying to close web
my son got to web my another son got to
Travis Travis mil the the high school
come on Travis I have a lot of problems
too. And he graduated the past year with
honors and right now is working in a
company here. But he was a student in
the teacher.
That is how it works. And here all the
people work with empathy with dedication
to the kids.
No, I understand.
>> And let me tell you something. I'm
afraid because I see in the news and
Instagram, Tik Tok, there are kids going
to another schools. They're suffering.
What his teachers doing uh painful to
the kids.
I'm afraid for my son.
I'm afraid for my son. You cannot say,
"Oh, he can't go to Houston. He can go
to Rodriguez."
It's not that easy
trying to explain my son the school is
got closed only because oh don't have
the standards
when he learning everything they know in
here
trying to explain to my son
you know what a outings is heart
and now you go take the only place my
son he feels safety.
>> It's not that easy.
>> [applause]
>> Um, so I wanted to ask if you could
address why Wedane is getting all these
exceptions when it comes to the plan.
So, originally before the plans were
released, we were told that if our
school closed, our students would only
go to a school that had a C or above and
that TAP principles would be required to
meet certain requirements to be employed
at the TAP school. Well, we have since
been told obviously they're not going to
a C school. They're going to a D and
another F school, a lower F than what we
had. But also, when we asked about
staffing, we were told, well, we have to
make another exception. So, we made an
exception about not sending them to a C
school, and we're probably also going to
make an exception for the principal at
Rodriguez because we don't have enough
principles that would probably meet
those requirements for all of the TAP
schools. So, why are we still
considering going through with a plan
when we have already been told we cannot
implement it as it's supposed to be
implemented?
>> Yeah, so great question. Um
my
what I would say is um
exceptions. We we we haven't asked for
exceptions. Um what I will tell you is
that
the Texas Education Agency
understands
how how many we have to to work through.
Right? As you heard Ally say, we have
13.
That's only three UAS. That's there's 12
more
right behind them. And so we as a school
district have 116 schools, which means
that about a quarter of the schools have
to go through these plans. And if you
are working through those many plans and
you don't um kind of recognize how any
one of these changes impacts the next
school and the next school and the next
school, you won't be successful. So
there's not necess there's not
exceptions. What we're saying is if you
were doing one thing in isolation, it
would fit in this box, which is what we
talked about. You know, certain
requirements, certain um definitions
regarding a highly effective teacher
because we are doing it all at once,
which has to be done.
Then we we are saying we can make these
adjustments, but we also have to invest
at these schools. So, um, what I will
say is that this is Woodedane is not the
only school that's going through, uh, a
transition that has some of these
differences and changes in it. There are
others. Um, just to be very, very clear,
it's not wood aim by itself. There are
many others. And when you think about
geographically where the schools are,
unless we're going to bus kids all
across town, which I'm not going to do,
right? We're not going to do that. This
is their community. they deserve to be
in this area. We have to find
alternative solutions. So, what I'm
saying is let's pitch a strategy that
responds to the largest elements in the
plan and then make adjustments and and
get it have it get accepted. That's that
is the approach we're taking. I am
confident that it will be uh accepted.
Um but to your point, these these aren't
exceptions like I'm asking them for an
exception. What I'm saying is this is
our district-wide plan. We don't have an
infinite number of principles. We don't
have an infinite number of teachers. If
we are going to try to make it work, it
has to work this way. Um, if there are
concerns in this specific adjustment in
this plan, I want to hear them so we can
refine and improve. But that's why it's
like that.
Yeah.
So if if we were so one of the things I
would say is to if we were to follow a
if if we were to be as rigid as the plan
the state requires, right? One one
option would be a dayto-day2
partnership, right? like we have that
across the street at Mendes. That is one
option. What I've heard from this
community time and time again is that if
they're going to be in our schools,
they're going to be AISD staff. That's
what I hear. So, we were responsive to
it. The other thing that I've heard and
is that we want familiar faces in these
schools. It was Ally who just mentioned
if the students if we are if this plan
gets approved and these students go to
Rodriguez and the others go to Houston,
our staff will have the option and
ability to go if they choose to go. I
want to make sure that our students feel
welcomed, that they have familiar faces.
That's how this works. If I have to
restart a campus and it's all new staff,
to me, that is further away from what
this community would want because you
would want your your staff there. I I
don't have the option of restarting
here. I don't have these other options
available to me in the way that we we
would have if it was years past or if it
was a different situation. So, we're I'm
trying to find a balance. It's not
perfect. it it's the the way that it's
designed the state tightens up as you
move through the process and I am trying
to find a solution that balances our
values supports our students and limits
disruptions but I do know that it's
disruptive
>> I'm going to go next we had a question
from Michelle O in the comment card um
has the district considered the impact
of the proposed closure of woodane that
it would have on the surrounding
services of the community such as the
library recreation center, etc. I do
want to start out with this question
because we had a similar question um
this morning. We were at Pickle
Elementary and they also they have a rec
center actually on site, a library, and
one of the things that we talked about
this morning was that um if it is more
convenient for families to pick up their
kids at the rec center because it's
actually closer. We talked about um kids
could theoretically go to the school
they're zoned to and then their bus
could take them back to and similarly I
think that we could potentially do a
solution like that rather than the
afterchool program being that your child
would participate at Rodriguez or
Houston they could actually just get on
the regular bus back to this
neighborhood if they wanted to
participate at the rec center and then
families could get them from the rec
center. So that was just one solution
that we were talking about that we could
potentially apply to here. I don't know
um if if you wanted to talk a little
more about this one.
>> So so our schools are are foundational
to our community. They just are right.
These are neighborhood schools. That's
why this is so painful. Like I I want to
acknowledge that this these schools
would in this community many like many
of our other schools in their
communities are anchors, right? That's
where community comes and and gathers.
That's where if there's an event like a
winter weather event, that's where
families come. Like we know that. I know
that we have set up winter weather
events. We've done vaccination sites.
These are community assets. So, have we
considered it? Yes. That's what makes
this so hard. Many other schools have
are going through this as well. So, if
this were to be approved, we would work
with our community to determine what
happens next. Right. I will tell you
that our board and myself are very much
aligned in wanting these as these these
schools to remain community benefits.
Now, it will depend on what that benefit
is for this community because it will be
different for some communities. Some
communities would prefer that it be, you
know, um community space or partner
space. Uh there's been um opportunities
for early childhood centers. We've done
that in schools that were uh closed.
We've had uh housing projects. We can do
lots of different things, but we're
going to do them with community. We're
not going to just uh go through a
process uh and just propose something.
So,
We have a systems
across the street
from school
every time they come back from the
doctor. That doesn't happen.
make us a national example considers us
an exception.
>> There's nothing like this. They don't
have a block rad.
[applause]
Why don't we have more electives and
specialized right now. Why does the
effect of consolidation
robust
access?
>> No, we we've we've we've actually
improved vacancies significantly. But so
that's your your point is is the is the
main
>> point
just like I'm old west mother my
children all graduated from deceas from
Austin Henry I mean
Garza Matthews they never went to a
meeting like this I never had experienc
Yeah.
>> You're not considered numbers. That is
why in the heck does elementary school
have an IV program and why do they pay a
Spanish teacher who isn't a native
Spanish speaker
to have that teacher
$250,000
just fornival
you all have left us.
>> So, so yeah, here's something
>> I that so I here's the thing.
>> I continue. I'm sorry.
>> She can come up.
>> She's She can You want to give her the
>> mic?
>> She can have the mic. I don't need one
right now. [snorts]
>> So
this is so I I agree with you that there
are huge inequities in Austin ISD 100%.
I I just talked about why if we do not
do something this is going to continue
for the next 50 years. We're 144 years
old. Breerwoods Cassiss Austin High all
the schools that you named. Think about
the feeder patterns. Think about the
alignment in curriculum. Think about the
supports they have. We are desperately
trying to find resources to deploy in
East Austin. The 2022 bond program was
an example of that that the investments
we made as part of the tax rate election
with instructional coaches or the are
the investments we made in our our
educators like we have been moving the
system precisely to do what you are
saying. The challenge that we have is
that the state has applied real
deadlines and milestones and I wish we
could have been back five years ago or
seven years making different decisions.
We did for whatever reason that didn't
happen. And so now we have to balance
>> the staff down here.
>> I don't think I I think that
why do all the schools in West Austin
have ABC ratings? Why? Why do we And I
have this question for you all and it's
in here. I want an audit of this school
over the last 10 years as far as test
scores. There is no reason why we should
see across the board test scores where
they go FFF BB FFF. That's a problem
with you all and the principles and the
administration
there. There should no excuse until you
can fix the inadequacies in your the the
environment we have already that we have
now. You can't fix that. Why are you
trying to fix us before you fix you all?
>> So,
[applause]
and another thing I don't see this
administration setting up schools for
success in the east side. Those schools
in West Austin are set up for success.
boy. Unbelievably, we are not. You do
not come in. You make it more difficult
for anything to happen, for us to do our
job.
And it
we need to be treated equally down here
over here. It doesn't need to be like
growing up where was the east side and
the west side.
>> People don't need to be embarrassed.
>> I agree. [screaming]
Miss, she means business, man.
>> No, but I really do.
>> So, so I just described how
>> makes no sense to these parents or even
>> one of the things that I said when I
started was that in 2022
had a B. In 2023, hang please let me
finish please.
>> When we got sixth grade in our campus.
>> Okay. So, hey, so going to be
>> exactly how no so the account
>> because of the principle
>> you we are agreeing I am telling you
right now that the 2022 accountability
to 2023 changed the they changed the
system in Texas you had the same
teachers the same students and they went
from a B to an F we had 12 schools that
were B's that now became Fs and
AC
>> they went A to see. So that's exactly
right. So so that's the thing in black
people start that we weren't addressing.
>> So the accountability system changed on
us and when the accountability system
changed it hurt our historically
underserved students to a greater degree
than the nonhistorically underserved
city groups.
>> I that's the state though that I I agree
with you. Thanks.
>> So the there's a there's a comment on
that.
>> There's a comment that was made here
around sixth grade because I want to
talk about that.
>> You mentioned sixth grade. You said
sixth grade made it well, you didn't say
it, but I think I heard you say it.
>> I did say it.
>> That sixth grade um being moved into
these uh elementary schools from Mendes,
>> right? made it more challenging
uh and ultimately made it more difficult
for each school to meet accountability
for a variety of reasons whether
certifications or the complexity of
having sixth grade coming in. What
happened in 2023? The administration
made that decision in April of that
year. You remember y'all remember that?
That was harmful. In April, the super
the administration made a decision and
then over the course of the summer,
everybody tried to move to try to get
our schools including Wedane prepared to
receive those students.
>> Rodriguez, Wedane, the list goes on and
on and on. It didn't work. That should
have never happened. I And that is one
thing that I'm telling our communities.
We cannot make decisions in the spring
semester, which is why we're having
these conversations now because I can't
take away the one thing that our
families absolutely need and what our
principles absolutely need. That's time
to plan. So there's other things that
happened in this community, but I just
want you to know that that is I agree
with you that created harm and I'm not
going to make those types of changes in
the spring semester. It's not going to
happen.
>> Uh my question is related more to
special education. I'm a teacher and a
parent and
AISD has been under fire for special
education violations left and right. Our
legal fees through the roof. That's
public record. The amount that we have
to pay to defend time and time and time
and time again. And somehow making the
like moving these babies here, we I mean
I have 50% sped in my classroom right
now. 50%
special education students in my
classroom right now. Do you know how
much support I get? Like none compared
to that. I have my amazing team here
that help me out. I would be nowhere
without our one special education
teacher, my one TA who comes in and
helps us out. That's it. That's all I
have for a 50% class of special
education. You're going to move them
and expect there to be smooth, no
violations, none of that. So those legal
fees that we already are paying out the
wazu, what is the plan to make sure that
we stay in compliance when we are
already out of compliance with special
education as it is in this district?
Already out of compliance.
>> So I would fix I'll push back on the out
of compliance piece, but
>> Oh, no, no, no, no. I I am a parent. We
are out of compliance on special
education.
>> So I agree with you. For the last two
and a half years, no. So two and a half
years ago, three years ago, before we
took on the TA agreed order, we had
thousands of evaluations back
>> thousands. Yeah. Okay. So we're at
hundreds now, right?
>> Well, no, we're way
>> you're not going to win this.
>> You're not going to win.
>> But to [laughter] say that we have not
been moving the system to improve, I
think and and
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, and then you talk about legal
fees that has gone way down like there's
a lot
>> answering that.
>> What's your question?
>> My question is what what is the plan for
these special education students?
Because if it is, we're going to give
them a transfer AR and we're going to
send some of their staff, who by the
way, most of us don't even meet the TAP
plan requirements, but you're going to
send our friendly faces over there and
that's going to fix it. I guarantee you
next year at this school, Rodriguez, you
are going to see massive behaviors and
all kinds of other issues that are going
to come up that are going to put us
right back in legal situations if we do
not address it. And so far the only
answer I have been getting been given
has been we're going to make sure they
they get their services at their campus.
That's not how that works. Don't say
we'll just send them services there
because you don't. That's that doesn't
ever happen.
>> And I I appreciate your question and
your comment and your concerns. Um I
hear you. We hear you. Um my name is
Christa Ethridge. I'm the interim
executive director of special education.
Um we have started proactively planning
very early. My team meets uh weekly.
Right now we're actually meeting almost
daily to um to really plan and look at
the data, look at the students
individually. Um it's like you said,
it's it we understand it's not just
going to we're going to move it and it's
going to work. It's going to take a lot
of planning. Um, and
>> yes,
>> so here here's so one of the things that
we talk about often
So,
>> everything
So with autism,
children needs things like that
transitions do not happen very well. We
know that. So we can't be like, "Oh,
>> can can I ask you what was what do you
think if this were to be successful? If
this has to happen, how can we be
successful? What do you need?
>> Massive intervention at the new schools.
You are going to need more than one
resource room. You are going to need
plenty of peace areas. You are going to
need trained staff, not trained on a
computer screen that we do at the
beginning of every year. You are going
to need handson trained staff by special
education individual like the TAs who
know their job as a TA, the teachers who
know their job, right? All of those
things, the staff who know those
students, they're going to walk in those
doors and they are going to panic.
They're going to run, they're going to
elope, they're going to do all those
things. And the amount of time we get at
the beginning of a school year in August
as teachers to plan, we already don't
get enough time to plan for the sped
students we have now. And that's
students who are returning and now we're
going to have a whole bunch of new ones
like that are going to have no idea
what's going all their safety is gone.
All those BIPs that we spend all that
time on, those are out the door there.
There's some outlines there. Yeah, but
they're in a whole new environment. So,
you're going to need to have a lot more
feet on the ground. And that's my
question. What What are those feet on
the ground going to look like at these
schools?
So what you're describing is precisely
why we need to make decisions now. You
you just mentioned sixth grade coming in
in April of 2023. One of the reasons
that we need to have a conversation is
so that we can build the plans together
like with the frameworks yes the
structure the expectations that I have
but I cannot build the plan unless your
voice is in it unless our family's voice
is in it. And if I start building that
plan in April and May, we will not be
successful at the start of the school
year. Which is why you need to start in
December and January so that we can
hire, we can position, we can pay the
siphons, we can get people to be in
place. I I'm being honest with you. If I
created a plan because if I created a
plan, it would not meet your
expectations. It wouldn't meet our
family's expectations because I don't
have that information yet. We don't have
a vote. This has not happened yet.
>> School make their own plan. Why don't we
do? Y'all need to stop and slow down.
Administration does. Every neighborhood
from around the entire district is
saying stop, slow down. You all push
this on us way too fast. Why don't you
all stop and slow down? Why?
Why in
your community? What will make this
work? Let us instead of wasting our time
all the time, let us have in school
meetings.
>> And and I I want to apologize for there
there are lots of things that should
none of us were this admit. We were not
here three years ago. Like there's
there's the the board there lots.
>> I know it's not your fault. It's not
your fault. It's our it's it's the
district's fault. It it is our fault. I
am desperately trying to find a way to
move us forward with the pressures that
are real like slowing down delaying the
state won't let us do that. This is a
>> threeway building that you all bought
that you should have never bought.
>> So,
so
much money I mean that
did y'all own it?
>> Uh, yes it was owned. How much did y'all
go by building that expensive?
>> So that is real estate. That's your area
of
it.
They're not selling. I mean, why would
you sell off that expensive piece of
property and not invest it back in? So
it doesn't
>> we have
>> So I am finding I am I am doing
everything possible to find funds. I I
we can certainly talk about
>> funds funds period not
>> ma'am ma'am can we try to one person
talk at a time I want to let him try to
respond please. Thank you so much.
>> Yeah. So, so in 2016, because that's
what we're going back to to talk about
that pro that um be that was mostly
before I got here, but the idea was to
consolidate four different sites. So, it
wasn't just central office at sixth
street. There was also the Baker
building, which some of y'all remember.
There was also the planning space out at
ALC at the time. So, AISC was operating
four buildings, all very, very costly.
And so the plan at the time, again, this
is previous administration. This is
before I got here. The idea was to
consolidate all of them, become more
efficient administratively. So that was
the decision. The real estate funds were
used to buy it because I didn't they
didn't no one wanted to take funds from
the general operating budget because
that's the budget that goes and pays for
compensation and for programs. So it was
a self-funded real estate offset. And
since then, we've been trying to find
more ways to monetize it. We've leased
out floors. We're doing everything
possible. But here's the thing. It is,
if we sold it, it would evaporate in a
moment because our budget is a billion
dollars. A billion dollars, right? We
give 700 million to the 780 million to
the state every year. Like if we if we
sold that building, you might get relief
for two months, three months, you know,
and then all of a sudden I'm going to be
having to figure out how to move
hundreds and hundreds of staff into our
schools, improve those spaces, probably
going to lose staff in the in the in the
place. And we talk about principles
needing support. All that comes from the
system. Like we're all together. So we
can go we can deliberate about it. But I
I want you to know that we are finding
every opportunity to generate revenue to
offset our cost. I have downsized
central office. I'm doing everything. I
told our community and I I will share
this with you all. Like I never wanted
to be here. We made lots of hard
decisions before we got here. We made
commitments before we got here. We're
just at a point where we have to take a
step forward if we're ever going to get
to to be a different school district
that actually can allocate resources to
where they're needed most. And I they're
needed in communities like this.
>> Okay. I don't have time.
>> We have about 10 minutes left. We
actually have another community meeting
in East Austin up at GR Greater Calvary
Bible School at 6 PM and it's about a 30
minute drive. So, um it looks like we
have I I know you haven't spoken.
There's four. I think we'll have time
for these last four questions. Um, and
then we're gonna have to get on the
road.
>> Hi, I'm not an educator, so um I'm kind
of drinking out of a fire hose right
now, but
um I'm kind of going back to Houston um
and Rodriguez and the tap kind of the
intersection of the tap and the um
consolidation.
So, my kids would be going to Houston if
this plan goes forward. Uh but I know
that from reading and from getting
information from other educators that
the tap is also tied to resources.
So what I'm understanding from AISD is
that my kids are not worth those
resources.
>> So to clarify both um Rodriguez and
Houston will get the extra resources for
turnaround.
So that's that's the problem. We don't
have funds.
>> I don't think your mic there you go.
>> Yeah. So So that's one of the things
that
>> we're we're that's your point is exactly
the point that I we are trying to make
is wherever we can. Right now we are an
inch deep and a mile wide. You got 116
schools all across the district. We have
needs. We have instructional co. There's
so many things that we need to offer our
students and we simply do not have the
budget. We're running a budget deficit
right now. But you and your staff had a
really big increase in salary recently.
So how do you justify that? [applause]
>> So when when was that?
>> Because I I believe there so since I've
been here the only salary increase
occurred in 2023, right? 23 uh was the
board vote. It applied for the 2324
school year. It's the same time that we
did 7% increase for teachers. We
increased stipens
>> and 34% for yourself. Correct. Or
something in the 30s. I haven't gotten a
pay increase since I started the job.
>> So, I mean I like I just want you to
know like I have none of our staff
>> I mean I could do an open record request
and get it. It's okay.
>> Yeah. No, that's fine. I I will.
>> But along those lines, since resources
are short, um how many staff at AISD
headquarters could we expect to also
lose our jobs since we don't necessarily
need that big of an AISD staff anymore
since there's going to be less schools?
>> Yeah. So um this past summer before we
even started this process we reduced our
central huh
>> okay so a so after okay so we just so we
took this is the third consecutive year
that we reduce central office staff
we're probably down 200 positions at the
moment whenever we think about what
positions have been increased they're
all around special education that's
really where we've seen the large the
largest number and instructional coaches
because they're coded to central office.
So if you go and look at just the total
number of staff, you're going to see
they're coded to central office, but
they're deployed to our campuses. So
there are lots of things like that. We
have we I will our board knows I think
they know our community knows I will
always try to reduce our like imprint in
the system. I've done that year over
year. Every single time we've had a
budget, I've reduced our staff. There
are people who have had um maybe not
demotions, but people who have changed
positions. We have
>> actual demotions. Yes.
>> Yeah. I've taken actual demotions. I
have held vacancies. I have vacancies
all throughout the district. I will not
post them. So, you look at the or chart,
there's vacancy, vacancy, vacancy,
vacancy all over. And I'm holding them
even though it's really impacting our
ability to support our schools because I
know how disruptive and how challenging
it can be to see that occur before we do
this. So, yes, I will always look for
opportunities to reduce our costs. I've
done it every single year that I've been
here and I will continue to do it.
>> Ma'am, I'm going to go to the gentleman
next to you because you've had the
chance to speak. So go ahead, sir. Are
you are you in line?
>> Did you have a followup?
>> Well, I one follow up with her. I think
we were thinking more executive
directors because if executive directors
are tied to campuses and we have 13 less
campuses, we don't need that many
executive directors, right? But my my
it's a common question in one. Um, and
what was bothering me is I feel like
when we're addressing our accountability
and these scores, we keep mentioning the
east side, the east side, the east side
in this community, right? And that the
test got harder. The state, the state,
the test made it harder or they changed
the test or accountability, whatever we
keep saying that they changed. Okay, I a
few years ago worked at the Harmony
Innovation right here. Many of you are
probably very familiar with. When I
first started at Harmony, it was an F
school. Ironically, because we got
scores from Jay Houston when Jay Houston
students moved over there. So, I went
through this same process with Harmony.
They did not throw their students under
the bus. They did not use their teachers
and their staff as scapegoats. They put
their boots on the ground. They gave
more resources. And that school over
[clears throat] the last three years
that took the same test has students
from the same community got a B and this
most recent year got an A. So, can we
please stop blaming the state and
talking about east and west because
obviously they have figured it out. They
have figured out how to be successful in
this community without displacing all of
their teachers and all of their
students.
>> So,
>> Matias, we only have five minutes before
you need to get on the road. So, I want
to get to the other questions.
>> Hello. [clears throat] Um, I am a
Did you have a question?
>> I'm not I'm not I I communicated what's
changed, right? I I don't I I am not I
am simply saying that we are in an
environment and the state has authority
and control and power. So, we have to be
responsive. I don't know what Harmony's
doing, but I can tell you that there are
lots of people have said, "Hey, um,
Menddees across the street, they have a
B. They have an A or a B and a B." And
so, so that's the thing. You can get the
results, but it may not be the way that
you want to get them. So, I am not going
to speak to that. I will never speak
about another school district. That's
not what I'm doing. That's not who I am.
But I I want you to know that I strongly
believe that whatever we do, it should
be done in alignment with our values,
Austin ISD values because you can get
quick results. It's happening in Houston
right now. They have great results.
That's not who we are. So, I just don't
want to go down that path. But I will
tell you that I am committed to making
sure that our students in Austin ISC
grow academically, but they also feel
comfortable in their own skin. They also
feel comfortable talking to someone look
like them. I mean, they're great humans.
like I I I appreciate and understand
that your position, but I wanted to
share with you just that response
because you asked for the response.
>> Hello. Um father of a a daughter that
goes to this school. Um love it. Um and
just want to say it's great hearing the
voice of the the teachers hopefully be
elevated tonight and actually want to
speak to how I know a lot of their faces
is exactly the follow-up question want
to have to hear is recognizing them from
the park or from the rec center or from
the event. um you know at the library
and I do not think you can find another
school we've looked at this you know
more connected than than weed and so I
almost want to rephrase the question is
have you considered that weedane is the
solution to this wicked challenging
problem that you have because I hear
about like staff retention what about
you know the ability to just go quick
take a quick jog or go check in on your
kid at the daycare or tie into a program
here at the library I think this would
be an awesome place to work and if you
need to retain the teachers, you got
these communities. I love this city. I
believe in this city. I believe in the
district. They're going to be building
towards these rec centers. They're going
to be building towards the park. We're
going to have mobility like we haven't
had in the future. There's a lot of
resources and synergy we can tackle tie
into here. And it does feel like I know
I don't understand the grading issues
and and how all that relates. But if the
question is how do you plan for
long-term best school location, this is
it. There's not another location. And I
can walk you through maps. I'm hoping
some of these made, you know, rounds
last time where it shows Wedane is the
most connected school. You talked with
Pickle this morning. It's just behind.
But there is not another school that
scores as strong as Weedane for
community connections. You got a
community schools program. It's here in
Austin. Only one on the south side.
Outdoor learning programs. Where is a
better spot to have in here? Let's work
with a golf course. Let's work with the
state park. Let's make this better than
anything else in the state of Texas.
There is a lot going on here that you
cannot find and it's going to be
irreoverable if we walk away. And I so I
the question is is we d the solution?
Are we walking away? Is AISD walking
away from this? Because there's a lot of
benefit and I'll say even if it's not an
elementary school, it feels like it
could benefit AISD in so many ways.
Thank you.
>> Hi. Um I'm a substitute teacher.
I'm the oldest person in the building
and possibly in the district and I've
been around and I'm a New York City um
native. I'm sorry to have to say this,
but I haven't seen this much snow thrown
around since I lived in New York. I come
I'm here every single day and I look at
the faces of my co-workers,
>> my co-workers, the administration, the
kids, and especially the parents.
Let's be honest, okay? You had the
meeting last week. You have this meeting
tonight. You're going to make a final
decision on November 20th. Be kind to
these people. Let's tell them right here
and right now. Is there any way in God's
good earth that you're going to keep
this school open? If you're not, be
honest and tell them it's over. Stop
with the bull.
So, as I as I I have never intended to
um you know to say anything that I
didn't believe was uh the honest truth.
So, uh we are refining the plan. We're
updating the plan. I can't say for
certain, sir, uh kind of where we'll end
up. I don't make the vote. That's the
board's decision. I have to address
multiple things. you're providing
feedback. I appreciate the feedback.
There was a comment this gentleman said
earlier that kind of is spurring, you
know, different ideas, but I I want to
be honest. Something has to change here.
I have to respond to the three UAS. I
just want to be really really clear.
That's not the board. That's not Matias.
That is the state of Texas requiring a
response and they expect the
intervention to meet the risk that they
see, which is 3Fs. Even if there's
progress, they still see it. And so,
investing in us.
>> All right.
She said that you're gonna go ahead.
>> I know.
>> Um, you're going to be uh putting our
kids in a place where there's bullying.
>> So,
So, please solve it. Uh don't don't just
uh close it. Um we're all a big family
here. Uh we're all a community.
>> Thank you. And
I have two daughters that studied here
and now they're at the university.
I have one in Boston,
one here.
>> That's something that's not always
possible, but uh with the teachers that
we have had here, that's something that
you can do.
>> Thank you. And this is going to be the
last question we have time for. Thank
you.
>> Hi, how are y'all? I have a different
energy tonight. Um my name is Steve
Rivera. I've been a classroom teacher
for about 36 years. Maybe a little less,
maybe a little more. Yes.
And um thank you. Um this is really a
very magical place, Mr. Sagura and um
Mrs. Pace,
how are you? I I want to say that
because
um this is a magical place. this
community, these loving teachers,
this awesome principal that we have, Mr.
Fosb,
he is topnotch.
Um, I I just want to say that
when I entered this building, Mr.
Sagura, I was a very young teacher.
Okay? So, twothirds of my time was here
at Wedane. So, this is my home away from
home. and I am coming to the end of my
journey. But it's saddened it feels very
sad to me because I've been working for
AISD since Dr. Ellis. I don't know if
any of y'all remember, but it it's been
long time coming. Dr. Foron, I've seen a
lot of administrators, a lot of
superintendent, a lot of teachers, a lot
of parents, a lot of students. And yes,
I've come from being the young teacher
to being the one who became a mom who
became a grandma and now a great
grandchildren. And it just feels so sad
to to to I cannot even believe that we
are here talking about White Day
closing. And I just want to say if
there's and I speak from my heart if
there is any way possible that this
beautiful campus would elementary it is
so special. It's so different than all
the other clos that are going to close.
I I've seen these schools that they've
been our sister schools for a long time
and nothing has taught Wedane. And I
know Miss Pace, I know that you know
this. You know me as a teacher. You know
that I worked really hard and all these
teachers that are here with me, Miss
Fawn, Mr. B, Miss Aila, so many teachers
that have been here since the the
beginning of time, we are special. We
are very different. Yes, you can give me
the F and everything that our children
have accomplished. But let me tell you,
this type of school, it's a very hard
school and it takes a very special
teacher. It takes a very special
principal and vice principal. It takes a
very special community to come. I can't
believe that this would come to a close.
Please, I beg you all with all of our
hearts. All of my heart as I tell you, I
came in as a very young teacher and I
will be leaving as a very old teacher.
But my heart it's here at Wedane.
What can I say? What can I do? How can I
plead? Keep Wedane open. I love these
children. Miss Face, you know us. you
know what we're about. You were part of
us. And then Mr. Fazband came in and he
continued and kept it just top-notch.
These teachers, I feel for them because
when I came into this profession in
AISD, oh my gosh, I couldn't wait to get
into AISD. I was I went to Taylor. I
went to California. Nothing topped AISD.
I feel so special and blessed that I've
worked here. Please, I beg you, don't
let AISD close at Wedane. This is a
magical place. Miss Wood, Miss Pace, you
know that. You know us. You know what
we're about. And Mr. Fosbonda, I don't
know about most of you, but we work day
in and day out with this gentleman and
he is awesome. He loves his children. He
cares about his teacher. He cares about
his community and this particular school
especially. It would be so sad to see it
all go away. Please, Mr. Sagura, I don't
know how to beg you. I don't know what
to do. But I beg you from the bottom of
my heart. I believe in AISD. My children
graduated from Austin High and Longhorn
country here. I I I just want I want
this for Wedane. It for it to close
would be just such a grave massive
mistake. I don't know how to tell you,
but if I wasn't here for twothirds of my
life, I would say, "Yeah, it's just
another school." But it's not. Most of
these parents, I probably had you all as
children. I don't know. But I already
know that I've seen so many kids go in
and go out. They come, they visit me.
This is really a special place. And all
these all of these campuses here, I
mean, all of these flags here, they
stand for something, especially for that
middle one. And it starts at Wedane.
I just want to say that I I I love Mr.
Fazbanda for having been the best
principal ever to have done what they
did. Miss Pace,
help us out. You know us. You know our
heart.
God bless you, Mr. Sea. I hope that you
reconsidered
in some way because this building cannot
it cannot perish. It has to be alive
with the children. All these parents,
God, if I could tell you what kind of
parents they are. Oh my gosh, they've
been backwards for this school. All of
these parents, I look at them. They
could be my children.
No, I'm serious. Look, I wear the ranks.
But I love Wedane Elementary and I've
known it forever.
God, if I can only just throw that magic
to you all that you don't understand
from this school, except for maybe Miss
Face, she knows what I'm talking about.
Anyway, Mr. Fosbond, for whatever it's
worth, thank you for everything
and may God bless Wedane Elementary. I
hope we're still considering that. Thank
you.
Thank you so much.
[cheering]
[applause]
>> Um before we head out, I just wanted to
reiterate the timeline so everyone is on
the same page. So, this coming Friday,
we will be um releasing revisions to the
plan. Um there's actually a a special
board meeting tomorrow night where
they're going to talk about some of
those revisions that you might see on
Friday. Um but you will get an email,
you'll get a text letting you know that
the plan is available and links to our
website, where to find everything. Um,
and then we will we have the board will
be actually discussing the actual
revisions next Thursday at their board
info session and then the November
voting session November 20th. That's
when we anticipate they're going to vote
on the the final plan. Um, and so if
you'll go one more slide um you still
have these at your tables. The um the QR
code, again, that QR code closes this
evening. So get your comments in. It's
actually probably going to close first
thing in the morning if you're a night
owl. So, there's still time to get
comments in the comment card. Um, we
thank you all for your time and we will
um you'll be hearing from us on Friday.
Okay. Thank you so much.